Continental Tire coaches corner as we
bring in the Kentucky head coach John
Calipari coach how are you this morning
dad how are you I'm great
did you recruit Penny Hardaway no he was
there before many years before I got
there but was a great Larry Finch
recruited him and who was Larry Finch
and Elvis were the two biggest things in
Memphis and then penny was right there
with them so and Penny is you know just
a great guy
terrific does a good job with the kids
and you know as a Memphis icon best
player you ever saw in high school you
remember um I saw LeBron I mean he was
ridiculous
I would say that was one thrown
cross-court bounce passes and his size
and then just being able to dominate
Jason Kidd was really good too by the
way
he was he could do whatever he wanted to
do as a high school player did you know
that LeBron wasn't yet you know I had no
chance but you still got to see him play
in high school well he was at the camps
okay you know so you saw him in Kevin
Garnett was really a good high school
player that way
who's the recruit that got away that
still bothers you I know it doesn't
bother me I don't take this stuff
personal the kids that want to come here
and play for us or me or wherever I was
I was finding the ones that chose to go
elsewhere you know I don't you know I'm
disappointed at the time it happens but
you know I'm you know but I miss on many
more than we get I mean you know what I
always say I'm overrated as a recruiter
but what is Oh said he lost out on Chris
Webber that that it still bothers him
but
those nuts there's why did you see the
tributes with Drazen Petrovic recently
with the with the Nets they gave out I
think I don't know if it was a some kind
of bobblehead or some kind of
commemoration of drazen petrovic and I
remember I was at CNN in New York and I
would get to see draws in play in New
Jersey unbelievable right I was just he
had so much bounce in energy and was not
afraid of anybody in the game right it's
just so sad just so sad and yeah like
you'd watch him and no one knew who he
was because you know European player but
you watch them and they're like oh my
gosh that's a deal you know to to be you
know in an accident that early in life
and and you know just it's a sad deal
but boy was he good when it's nice of
the Nets to do that and you were
coaching him right know you don't know
chance that was before no mm-hmm that
was probably two or three years before I
took the nets and four or five before I
got fired by the Nets I don't know if I
covered you when you were with the net I
don't remember I I remember you being
there I don't know if I was still
working at CNN I might have gone to ESPN
after that you were the spm when I was
at UMass so you were the Hadean when I
was with it when I was within that okay
all right and and then you went Nets
you're one of those guys that you forget
about people quickly listen help you
mister and they're done yeah they're
yeah and then later you say you look at
impact
you're looking at name tags like who is
this guy Oh John I remember you Hey once
you dropped out of the top 25 I said
there's no original Avion yeah I was
done right I've been begging to come and
then all of a sudden your team started
playing defense and listening to you and
then all of a sudden
John Calipari is a great coach once
again no they'd never say that but the
team is has come together and you know I
got a great bunch of kids you know what
week we did this Facebook thing and
there's like it's like an all-access and
I don't do all accesses I just I don't
well let me give a fish only
introduction inside the madness Kentucky
basketball it's a 10-episode series that
just started airing it's produced by our
for Facebook watch which is Facebook's
brand-new home for original programming
all right yeah so they came in and
initially I said no but then I wanted
the players and I said do you guys want
to do this it's a great opportunity for
people to get to know who you are we you
are the youngest team to ever undertake
what you're about to do never before in
the history of our game and you're great
kids
you're good students you're good you're
good to each other you're good to you
just in experience and don't know crap
you don't know anything but this would
be a great Avenue if you want to take it
and they also they came back and said
we'll do it because they don't know
better but then it kind of dry you know
now all of a sudden it's like we're in a
four-game losing streak and they're
saying could we put this mic on you I
said how about if I put the mic around
your neck and choke you I mean I mean
it's you know but we went through it and
I treated up like they weren't there I
literally didn't look at him didn't care
just go ahead and and it's transparent
but you get to know these kids see the
problem we have right now in basketball
everyone thinks that these kids these
kids those kids don't belong on a
college campus that is so wrong so wrong
yesterday and I didn't see it so I
probably shouldn't comment on it but
that never stops me Tony Kornheiser will
bomb and coordinators are going back and
forth about my statement of don't
devalue education and Tony says well
come that shouldn't come from cow wait a
minute why are you and I like Tony like
I really like Tony are you telling me
that my kids don't belong on a campus so
we shouldn't talk are you talking about
kids while they left that devalues
education no it doesn't one they all
have lifetime scholarships
dakari Johnson Julius Randle and now
John Wall
I believe Brandon Knight I've already
started come
back to finish degrees and it's gonna
take some time so wait you talked about
pandemic lis wait they have a lifetime
scholarship they are getting okay I
didn't know that yeah they can come back
whenever they choose to but we've had a
thousand on this APR how they rate us
we're in the top 10% academically
because our kids all even good academic
standing so they can come back and
finish I'm exactly who should talk about
the academics this stuff where these
kids don't go the second term that's a
bunch of crap and again we're in a
country right now if you say something
enough just say it over no it's becomes
true they don't go they don't go they
don't go second term they don't it's all
a bunch of crap so this program gives
you an idea of what college kids that
are going through what my kids go
through or doing that's the one in done
work okay
Hey look here's what it is for those
kids it's a gap year yeah you know I've
heard this one you know these kids
aren't prepared well you're drafting
them at 19 and 18 years old 19 years old
I should say in 20 don't do you say my
kids aren't prepared we've had 19
lottery picks guess what they're all
getting to 2nd and 3rd contracts so
you're saying my kids are prepared my
kids won the community assist award John
Wall Anthony Davis DeMarcus Cousins
getting involved you're telling me my
kids aren't involved or not not really I
don't think y'all are singly I don't
think people are necessarily singling
you out
I think talk about this if you're saying
in a blanket none of these kids are
ready don't say that there's some that
aren't you know some of mine aren't and
and why they shouldn't have gone and I
told them that but when they choose to
go I support them and then when they get
there they say oh my gosh you know it's
it's a little different here let me give
you a couple things because I do like to
hear you speak but one kid should be
able to go out of high school yes but
how do we do that without the valuing
education now I'm going to give you some
names Sebastian Telfair jeremy Tyler
Leon Smith Robert Swift Leon Smith
Robert Swift Jonathan bender Kwame Brown
I mean those are kids that you probably
don't even know who they are but they
were out of high school and didn't make
it
what if that's now kids all going like
they were going to encourage them to go
to the d-league and they don't make it
we can have a list of a thousand of
those 2,000 of those and then I asked
you this who's going to take care of
them we just had the highest graduation
rate on the African American basketball
players in the history of our sport last
year you know how many of those kids
thought they were one and done or two
and done most of them probably 90% of
them yeah
but they stayed in school when they got
it our kids got have lifetime
scholarships and because we do it you
know other schools are doing it too now
that they can come back when they need
to here's my thing Players Association
needs to be involved in this Players
Association and I've talked to Michelle
about it do a combine for juniors take a
hundred of them tell the ones that need
to go to college good you need to go to
school you 15 or 12 you need to go
directly to the NBA but let them know
how about this the Players Association
oversees the agents we'll figure
something out where these parents can
get advisors or be advised with you
there as the Players Association so now
take this stuff I don't want to hear one
of my players talk to an agent or his
family look make it legal if you're
going to pin it on me when they're in
another city or another state or out of
the country and it comes back to me then
make it legal and the Players
Association can do it you ready for this
you decide to go to college
let the Players Association give these
families loans so the take they can
travel with their teams if they choose
to move to a town where their son is
going to play they can take a loan and
do it instead of having families move to
towns how do I actually did get there
let that be legal what about if agents
loaned you know had loan
two players loaned the money and
everything was above board that you're
loaning them money that you make it I
would say I would say why not let the
Players Association do it why even have
a third party let me let me explain
these parents have dignity and don't
want anyone else in their business but
if they have nothing when you open up
their refrigerator and there's a can of
corn in there and someone's offering
them money they're gonna take it but
they don't want to take it they'd rather
do their own thing with their family you
know why no one's ever done anything for
them you think they trust some white guy
walking in and giving them money they
don't trust that they know what this is
when you in this country that we're in
when you have nothing you ready
you can't get anything you can't get a
coke a hamburger a quarter when you have
everything you need I need nothing
they give me cars they give me clothes
I'd never pay for a meal like we got
this backwards these families if you
help them here's a treat it like
Olympics these kids own their rights
their name their likeness their
autograph if they want to sign
autographs for money let them do it it's
theirs if the school wants to control it
somewhat fine if you want to put it in a
fund fine but here's my point
do we want and it's a question we have
to answer I'm not saying this in a mean
way do we want the NBA controlling all
of these kids in all of their lives
it is not minor league baseball minor
league baseball has single a double a
triple a you can last nine years you
know what else minor league baseball
does as the 17th round pick you can get
a signing bonus and you ready
they will guarantee your education it's
not like here you come for two years and
then go do we really want to encourage
let me say this it's a white sport
unless you're Dominican but if you're
Dominican you're owned by a club in
Dominican Republic and they Major League
Baseball has to pay for your rights so
you have to be sold that way okay
give me one rule that you would like you
only get one
what's the one thing why do I only get
what everybody only gives me one stuff
I'd like to I like I'm selfish I like
more than one I'm only gonna give you
one cuz you know what you didn't deserve
it this year yet let me see how you do
at the end of the year I don't know
coach okay look I I think again we have
no control whether kids should go out of
high school to the NBA that's between
the Players Association and the NBA no
control okay what I believe we should do
these kids they already have a program
where these kids get loans for
disability insurance if you're eligible
for the disability insurance because
Lloyd's of London said you have Pro
potential you should also be eligible to
get a loan for your family to travel to
eliminate all this third-party crap do
you go do it
you can do it yourself as a family that
would be the major thing and then the
second thing because I'm not taking just
one would be the likeness the signing
treating them like Olympians now
well everybody wouldn't be treated the
same this isn't communism we don't
always get treated to say more skilled
they get more than you get okay because
that's how this country well let's say
it's an open market right now and let me
say this hold on before you speak okay
whatever we do kentucky's eating first
so I'm not I'd rather coach guys for
four years okay but I'm saying what are
we doing for these kids do we really
trust again the NBA to be about the kids
are they going to be about the NBA do
you tell me maybe they can come up and
say we'll give them all signing bonuses
every kid that comes out of high school
and we'll guarantee their education you
know what I'm for that let's go sign me
up short of that I'm on the other side
and I don't care if the President of the
United States says it's a good thing I
will be on the other side because why
would we devalue education when that's
the one hope to get people to the other
side of the tracks that's the hope not
the dream of I'm going to be and you're
14 years old you're damn Patrick
bad decisions did you make but let's
just talk about when you're 14 and 15
and your choice is I'm gonna be an NBA
player or I'm gonna really work in
academics and get my education what are
you picking you know which one you're
picking I'm gonna be a problem and have
a big house I'm gonna have a watch I'm
gonna have the nice car man it really
what about 1% make it and then we're
affecting one group of people because we
know it do us about african-american
young people what are we doing for them
how do we make sure they're making the
right decisions for themselves which is
going to affect them the rest of their
life do you know do you ask your kids if
anybody's taking anything that that like
it's not even you know with the booster
or the coaches or anything that you know
an agent can get to these kids early and
give them $25,000 loan like how do you
know if your players come in and they're
not bringing any baggage with them well
truth be told you don't know but our
compliance would meet with them and meet
with their families and go through
anything if there are any issues let's
deal with it we will walk through this
and deal with it but our compliance does
that cuz they could hide it you know
there's usually not a paper trail you
know and you know what I say and I've
been saying for years one we shouldn't
have summer basketball for me I think
I'd rather be with my own players and my
own family second thing you ready if the
coach cannot control it make it legal
because if I have no control over it and
you're gonna say I'm responsible for it
yeah make it legal yeah make it legal I
don't care what it is make it legal if
you're gonna tell me something happens
in their high school make it legal if
something happened in their hometown
make it legal if something happened with
them and it'd make it legal but but I'll
say this again I'm not here to say I
want one and done I'm here to tell you
what's best for these kids going right
out of high school for 15 do we upset
this whole system for 15 twelve eight
kids seven kids nine kids 12 kids even
if it's 20 kids we have this thing when
you start talking these graduation rates
and things
are happening and high schools preparing
these kids for college better than they
ever have because they have to be
eligible to play in college when I
coached in the Dominican Republic one of
the things I told them that would be
different with basketball in Dominican
than baseball in basketball they'd have
to go to the United States or go to a
team but education can be a carrot now
for all these kids in Dominican to get
to the United States to get education
and many of them will not be NBA players
but they're going to be educated and can
come back to Dominican Republic now and
then lead your country that's what I
said when I took over basketball for two
years it was about the education and I
know again I am one of the first prop 48
coaches and people out there that know
what prop 48 men Woods I was barely
eligible or wasn't eligible but my
family the strides my own family has
made has been based on academics and the
NCAA please if the NCAA encourages you
ready for this
if the best 12 players Dan go to the NBA
do we really need a you have to stay in
school two or three years you're going
to school cuz you're gonna have to stay
to or three years or you'd go right to
the NBA you're yelling you don't need
your you're young horse who's yelling
you're you're young yeah it's Italian
when you're around at dinner - my wife's
it's a hard you got to talk louder than
the other guy okay I love talking to you
I don't know we talk I think you yell at
me the SEC Tournament Friday Kentucky
plays the winner in Missouri versus the
winner of Georgia who cares all right
we'll check in with you at the Final
Four okay okay coach thank you there's
Coach Cal he was brought to you by
cotton entire coaches corner Continental
Tire proud to be the exclusive tire the
Dan Patrick show no matter where you
drive or what you drive Continental
designs tires for what you do for more
information visit content
Icom Continental Tire for what you do
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]